[Musica]
beh il tema è come costruire una squadra
vincente ma anche il tema principale di
questo evento è anche che priorità
dobbiamo dare no ognuno nel proprio
campo come bisogna ri adattarsi a questi
cambiamenti che stiamo affrontando e
quindi ci sono delle delle modifiche che
anche io sto facendo nel cercare di
costruire e di gestire una squadra che
deve tendere all'eccellenza
per prima cosa la mia priorità nella di
testa da quella di andare alla ricerca
dell'eccellenza sia da giocatore che da
allenatore e quindi ho messo lo sport e
direi lo sport agonistico come priorità
la mia vita sacrificando anche anche la
famiglia
quindi dare delle priorità credo che sia
fondamentale soprattutto quando ci si
deve seguire una passione e dopo questi
cambiamenti la domanda che ci dobbiamo
fare se
la priorità dello sport è ancora ancora
valida
beh io direi di sì perché lo sport
inteso come attività fisica
aiuta lo dicono i medici sono tutti di
logiche che ascoltiamo in televisione
durante
queste serate che aiuta a
migliorare le difese immunitarie e
quindi sicuramente sì fare attività
fisica importante e lo sport agonistico
chiaramente lo sport agonistico la
passione non finisce mai e ancora molto
valido e ancora molto bello perché
perché è una sfida che tu hai con te
stesso prima di tutto oppure se fai uno
sport individuale oppure se sei
nell'ambito di una squadra
vediamo come bisogna interagire affinchè
la squadra possa arrivare all'eccellenza
nel gioco di squadra
ripercorriamo un pò questa questa
pandemia noi siamo una squadra nel 2019
ha vinto il titolo di campione del mondo
quindi vinciamo la medaglia d'oro e ci
apprestiamo a vince a cercare di vincere
una medaglia olimpica lenti 20 15 e
grande entusiasmo c'è una grande
grandi obiettivi una grande motivazione
e naturalmente a marzo del 20 20
iniziano le prime difficoltà inizia il
primo lock down e siamo stati come la
maggior parte degli sportivi tre mesi
senza poter andare a non solo a
competere ma anche allenarci
perché comunque le piscine erano chiuse
quindi i giocatori non avevano
possibilità nelle proprie città di
potersi allenare siano stati tre mesi
chiusi una forte motivazione una certa
la resilienza una capacità di
adattamento ci siamo adattati a questa
situazione abbiamo creato un canale
youtube per cercare di coinvolgere tutti
gli esercizi fisici da casa era un
minimo per avere il contatto della
squadra e cercare di avere sempre ben in
mente la motivazione che era quella
delle olimpiadi che per un mese ce l'hai
e poi dopo un mese in mese e mezzo ci
dicono che le olimpiadi vengono
posticipate di un anno quindi grande
sconforto
e quando si riapre il paese la prima
cosa è stata quella cerchiamo di
recuperare il tempo perduto e non
buttare al mare quattro anni di lavoro e
quindi ci siamo radunati in bolla per
due mesi
che è stata da una parte una possibilità
di riprendere l'attività fisica che
stare o non stare in acqua per tre mesi
è veramente dura però dall'altra è stata
un'altra chiusura
dei giocatori dei ragazzi per cui da una
parte c'è stata la ripresa la voglia di
riprendere a fare quello che si ama
dall'altra c'è stata ma
vuoi dire a livello mentale è stata una
pesantezza livello mentale nel dover
fare questi due mesi senza l'obiettivo
immediato quindi poca tolleranza
quindi
piccoli conflitti tra i componenti della
squadra e quindi
è stato pesante gestire questo periodo
poi si e ripresi da settembre con un
periodo di cose positive o negative
fin quando c'è stato un ulteriore
chiusura quindi i campionati dimezzati e
quindi
c'è stato un periodo molto difficile da
gestire
che priori d'andare in questi periodi la
priorità è quello di tutelare lo sport
il nostro sport che poi è il nostro
lavoro e questo è anche un gioco di
squadra
come l'abbiamo fatto e stato un
iniziativa del presidente federale che è
per tutelare lo sport ci siamo
autotassati
del 20 per cento nel nostro stipendio
per aiutare le società
senza le società
non c'è lo sport di alto livello quindi
c'è stata una
un aiuto reciproco
e quindi in questi momenti è una
priorità
è stato fatto con estrema naturalezza
con estrema
partecipazione anche emotiva
quindi questo è un primo momento di fare
squadra
quindi bisogna aiutarsi l'un di collauto
bisogna comunicare
bisogna parlare interagire non chiudersi
questo in tutti i campi
adesso stiamo parlando a livello di
federazione che siamo una squadra siamo
all'interno della squadra
coni
è la nostra squadra deve saper
interagire
siamo andati alle olimpiadi dove non
abbiamo ottenuto un risultato che tutti
ci aspettavamo
e la domanda è stata perché
la squadra non ha abbiamo sbagliato
qualcosa ma può essere ma la realtà è
che la squadra
non è stata una squadra cento per cento
quando la squadra non funziona non c'è
talento che tenga
non c'è
qualsiasi exploit individuale deve tener
conto del
nell'equilibrio generale
ogni
componente della squadra deve dare un
qualcosa in più deve lasciare qualcosa
di personale alla squadra invece sono di
fuori probabilmente
per tutta questa componente di
situazioni è venuto fuori più l'egoismo
rispetto alla generosità che bisogna
dare nei confronti degli altri quindi il
talento non basta la resilienza che
dicevo prima che secondo me poteva
essere un motivo fondamentale per andare
avanti non basta
non basta se non si pensa la squadra
dove ognuno deve avere dei ruoli dei
compiti ben precisi
rispettare le le poche regole che si
danno
e combattere i propri individualismi e i
propri egoismi
bisogna combatterli
perché squadra che si vince
questo è un
elemento che batto sempre nella gestione
del del mio gruppo noi siamo stati una
squadra
che nel 2009
siamo arrivati undicesimi ai campionati
del mondo di roma il peggior risultato
storico se andate a vedere l'albo d'oro
del settebello ha vinto tantissime
medaglia quell'anno campioni del mondo
come allenatore in panchina abbiamo il
peggior risultato storico
dove ognuno pensa a se stesso a
scaricare perché la coppa è sempre
nel compagno o dall'allenatore o della
federazione o del presidente del
consiglio del presidente del coni mai
nessuno che si chiede se ci stiamo
allenando bene o se ci sia o se stiamo
giocando bene la mia risposta era no lo
stiamo giocando bene non ci stiamo
comportando da squadra tutto il
movimento fa la nota una vittoria del
settebello è una vittoria del movimento
con la moto tutti i componenti devono
partecipare per poter vincere e tutti
sono
importanti nessuno indispensabile ma
tutti sono molto importanti con questo
cambio di mentalità due anni dopo ai
campionati del mondo di shanghai 2011
siamo passati dall undicesimo posto al
primo posto
quindi quando si si pensa la squadra si
ottengono risultati impensabili e quando
soprattutto
si vive l'uno per l'altro
e allora noi abbiamo battuto squadre
nettamente più forti di noi
io né ai giocatori dico se giochiamo da
squadra possiamo battere chiunque se
giochiamo individualmente c annullano
perché sono più alti più forti più sono
dieci centimetri più alti notano più
veloce sono più forti fisicamente
e allora
se invece giochiamo da squadra coesi
compatti
ecco la compattezza
e una cosa che la squadra avversaria lo
percepisce quando una squadra è compatta
quando una squadra non si abbatte alle
prime avversità quando subisce anche
delle giustizia dell'arbitro ma sei
focalizzato subito all'azione successiva
e questo è un allenamento e queste sono
delle cose che un leader e un allenatore
manager deve fare deve impartire due tre
cose fondamentali
chiaramente deve conoscere perché non si
può bluffare devi dire delle cose
sensate deve essere e saper comunicare
perché devo entrare nel cuore delle
persone nel cuore dei giocatori quando
parlo
sia che si tratta di natura tecnica si
natura tattica uno di natura strategica
o anche di natura etica comportamentale
perché anche quello alla sua ha la sua
importanza
se dimostri di avere una medica
superiore i giocatori lo apprezza
e allora possiamo essere più forti e poi
devi essere giusto
questa è una cosa molto importante
essere la correttezza e la giustezza
allora ti fanno accettare anche delle
scelte impopolari io ho fatto anche
delle scelte
che ho messo fuori prima di partire per
le olimpiadi giocatori che si
aspettavano di essere di far parte della
squadra
gli ho spiegato le cose ma se sanno che
io sono giusto magari lì per lì si
incavolano però poi lo accettano perché
sanno che io lo faccia nell'interesse
della squadra perché sono giusto e
corretto e comunque lo comunico
e questo diventa di fondamentale
importanza
adesso le olimpiadi non sono andati bene
certo vincere all'impiedi importante ma
in questo momento è ancora più
importante fare squadra nel momento
difficile
nel momento difficile e tutti danno la
colpa all'altro è facile disgregarsi
è in questo momento la squadra di
riunirsi ancora di più e diventare
ancora un blocco unico
non esaltarsi di fronte alle vittorie
non abbattersi e di fronte alla
sconfitta è facile diventare presuntuosi
dopo che si è vinto e lo abbiamo
dimostrato nel 2019 che abbiamo vinto è
i ragazzi si sentivano
di essere i migliori in assoluto no non
è così perché il giorno dopo gli
avversari vogliono essere subito più
forti di te
e non l'abbattersi non sentirsi
eccessivamente in colpa quando ci sono
delle delle sconfitte bisogna analizzare
analizzare serenamente far passare
l'arrabbiatura dopodichè avere maggiore
grinta e maggiore determinazione
nell'affrontare
le nuove competizioni nelle nuove stime
ai giocatori alla ripresa del collegiale
che c'è stata insomma qualche settimana
fa ho detto una frase che ho visto nei
muri di wimbledon il tempio del tennis
if you with the triumph of disaster
tridem segue
se incontri nella tua vita il trionfo o
il disastro trattare la stessa maniera
perché sono due impostori
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]